so a 29 year old Pennsylvania man was
recently arrested because he was trying
to warn everybody in his area that
aliens are gonna come and take over the
world because humans are bad and he was
warning people by making a makeshift
bomb and leaving it at a hotel he
actually went inside the hotel told the
manager hey I made this cool bomb and
the manager said please bring it outside
call the police and he was arrested yeah
well I like this guy he sounds like he's
not dealing with a full deck he is
certain that the aliens are gonna come
for us okay
hey that's called being certifiable you
know crazy needs help right I don't know
man
it looks pretty cool to me that's pretty
cool I mean it's pretty cool to me like
try it's in schizophrenia hits men in
their 20s you know that anyway talk
about aliens do you unsee the [ __ ] in
area 51 dude on Rogen
I didn't you haven't seen it no what's
his name his name Glaser Lazar oblast at
me cuz if anyone needs to see you me
slide dude [ __ ] why healings are real
bro I was just walking listening I know
that's what you everything on Netflix
like I know I'm usually the anti cancer
AC guy but you know what I've looked
into it Hunter and Eddie's kind of right
[ __ ] I'm not trying to fist you not
threatening bro I'm threatening you
right what what I swear to God what [ __ ]
aliens are real they are bad the real
you are you are you an alien so real I
don't think there's any heavy dolls you
[ __ ] okay take it easy [ __ ] do you say
there's no evidence hey this ba blazer
worked on you after you're getting.i
calmly sir okay colons way cool he do
aliens you should be called okay later
right laser you butcher every name but
lasers what like so laser laser believes
no no not believed dude he was laser out
there was brought there worked on nine
different UFOs we have video he worked
on nine different nine of them at area
51 dude if you discredit laser i'ma [ __ ]
you up I just feel like wants to you
okay I just
guys want to say one thing is it
possible that he is a liar why would he
why would mr. [ __ ] do you believe in God
that cleans his nails with a [ __ ]
knife and scribe several because I was
trying I mean reals try to warn this guy
actually worked with UFOs on a very
secured area 51 guys words they have
granny on it do not educate yourself
before you do there are aliens are real
aliens are real I would bet my bottom
dollar made contact with us
they sure have sure on earth yeah have
we have there's one space nine of them
nine what did you know hey dude Brian
won't you grab your phone real quick
your iPhone you don't believe in a you
sound like this guy who put a bomb in
the [ __ ] and that I sound like an
educated human being it is easy don't
believe in a are you have your hat off
and why are you pointing at me just
relax supreme expensive okay dude you
don't believe in aliens I don't know
about aliens but I don't know that we
have nine spaceships all right I would
love that what do you think we're in
here he said he worked on him what did
he do on and they soup them up I'm
asking I'm asking questions drive me
crazy bro I don't know can I tell you a
story real quick yes he's just real
quick please so chris d'elia is amazing
on the road now right he's opening for
me yeah we get to this one town every
city that we go to were the funniest
guys there yeah anywhere we go to a
coffee bean we go to a Panera Bread were
the funniest [ __ ] people to walk in
yeah you don't we get to this town funny
posse it's it's called I think it's
called Dayton Ohio I think I'm pretty
sure you behind there we got a date and
all of us so we're not the funny people
everywhere we go the Panera we go to
[ __ ] in some restaurant and everyone's
odd everything everything is a lot so
Chris and I go to the room and we start
laughing and we're like dude you know
what this town is the government that
built this town because this is where
they breed aliens and then they breed
them here and then they ship them out
into the regular world so how do they
work here like they work with them here
to deal with like people that are
transient coming through and dealing
with regular humans right we were
laughing we're dying so hard at this
theory right so the guy that comes and
picks us up for the for the show he
driving us to the to the to the show and
and then chris is sitting in the front
seat I'm sitting in the back and I go
hey my man um are there any aliens or
spaceship set that uh fly around here
and we just we giggle to ourselves Chris
and I are laughing to ourselves right
and the guy goes yeah uh roswall crashes
here the the spaceship from Roswell
Roswell right Roswell Roswell the
Roswell spaceship is here and it's in
hangar let's check this out he goes chin
you you and you're on the alien train as
well I've always kind of believed it I
believed it the best part of the story
he goes the Roswell crash is here it's
in hangar like 52 you can look at hangar
18 hangar 18 I swear to god Chris and I
we were laughing all day all day we were
laughing when this guy said this Chris
night we look [ __ ] ghost face we look
at each other like what the images Brian
you don't think it's inbred leadership
this is a real hater in Dayton Ohio that
looks like a hangar now listen let's
loosen no we were joking around about
this whole alien [ __ ] that guy said that
to us it freaked us the [ __ ] out because
that's literally how that town felt it
felt like they were like breeding up
human yeah I'm just saying it it was
really sad there might be a hoof oh
alright well that's my story that's
Chris crystal be I'm telling you gotta
listen to this Bob laser Lazar I'm just
those are Lazar now he has a
documentarian that that's so fake the
documentarian that's with him is a bit
of a tool where you Mike I don't believe
this yeah but this Bob laser guy it's
real [ __ ] man yeah hmm yeah why were you
so I just said I said was mm-hmm
you don't believe in any of it you know
all I said was life form I just said hmm
yeah you crazy man guys I'm not saying
I'm not saying extraterrestrial life
doesn't exist of course it has to you'd
have to believe it does because the
universe is so huge but and there it was
they what lads aren't as they have so
what Lazar was saying laser Lazar was
saying is you don't even know his name
but keep car well not calm laser cuz way
cooler so what he was saying is the
technology that so that his whole
project was to figure out how these
things work like the energy source is so
much more powerful than ours that he was
a scientist at yes rocket scientist why
the government abilities jets at the age
of 13 out of his house would you say why
the government why did the government
there's now he doesn't know he goes they
do I have no idea why they won't tell he
goes I thought it was because we want to
advance in our technology we should let
everybody know but the government
doesn't think that way some people this
is government yes so well it's all
government so some people think that the
government doesn't really see cuz it
released mass hysteria because their
technology is so much more advanced than
ours they could just [ __ ] blow up the
world at any point yeah and also all
religion would be faked in right yeah
100 yeah it's all [ __ ] but I mean I
appreciate that I don't know what was
your stance on it they'll be what do you
use I stand in my stance is that I just
can't I can't
so so you have to think about this for a
second let's just say the government
which is always changing right people in
power die new people come in so I mean
no I guess the military also generals
retire and you have new people come in
the struck and it have to be some kind
of there have to be some kind of law or
some kind of agreement written rule
among whoever it might be to say this
stays secret you know harder to keep
secrets all of us are like hmm and in
people in government I don't like this
[ __ ] right so you don't think there's
secret well this was in the government
the national security state Calder's
that's what I'm saying is that there are
national security secrets right so for
sure we're doing their stuff Alison's we
have no idea let's just take it we have
a UFO let's say we have a UFO yeah
and it's somewhere and one of these
hangars in to them explain to me the the
how in the world would anyone especially
I say what how long has it been there do
they say like they don't know the 13
year 1920 okay good
even so so we've kept this a secret for
you know a hundred years explain to me
how that would be so and how people
came in the power wouldn't say dude this
is fascinating how investigative
journalists scientists who are so
curious about CIA people military people
wouldn't somebody go dude there's a
[ __ ] UFO here it'd be the greatest
most incredible thing with it be all of
us all this would be lining up to go see
this thing right
what do you don't want that how who's
they don't want the who's they who who's
they
the government wouldn't want that when
you say the government who in the
government the government is is
multi-layer so but you guys smell
different you thought you're pretending
that the government everything's out I'm
say 400 years you're not gonna keep a
secret for a hundred year you don't
think the government knows rules that
type of information system goes in at
all Society like imagine imagine if they
said that there is a higher life form
and that there's a nobody can keep a
secret for 100 years it's not possible
and I think about it there's a you don't
think for a hundred years yeah come on
when the government there's a UFO in a
hangar somewhere and somehow we said you
get into a room when you're in the CIA
or the military come there this has been
passed on from generation to generation
there is a you as well but we must keep
it a secret from the people not know
what no oh but only certain branches
work on it so the whole not everyone's
Eve is into it what branches let's just
say it's the brat let me give you
numbers you know area 51 it's a real
complex cracker okay but but I'm saying
and that's a secret yeah but but but
that's might be secret technology to the
government secret technologies right
weapons today you're contradicting
yourself that's the technology that but
I'm saying that that is because we keep
it secret from Chinese espionage Russian
espionage things like that losses well
right yeah robotics and all that stuff
so and and and by the way that there's a
lot of industrial espionage so a lot of
that a lot of that technology comes out
of industry Boeing Lockheed even Apple
and those people have their own kinds of
things right and so now they have
certain areas that are highly secretive
so an apple but comes out with a new
technology the [ __ ] secrecy is crazy
around that right so everybody has an
interest in keeping that so that that
proprietary stuff that you can make
money off of it doesn't get stolen I'm
talking about a UFO that's been
forever that came from maybe forever
that's just me I don't know wouldn't you
but you're saying you don't even justify
because the government hasn't come out
and told you about that yeah oh that's
silly what's the justification you know
30 years 40 years of a UFO why why
wouldn't I be able to see it wouldn't
everybody be curious no how would you
keep all those people how many have no
matter all that Holly okay well what do
you mean people's life so let's say 15
people worked on it let's say 15 people
right cuz that laser was there I doubt
they retire and then what or some died
from radiation from work whatever okay
all of them have died from radiation
okay so whatever that yeah cuz it's so
power right okay but so we know that but
but please tell me where in the where is
due but we're in legislature let tell me
where it says you're not allowed to talk
about this well you somebody in Congress
are wouldn't cuz I'm meeting Congress go
uh no no hold up Navy SEALs can't talk
about their missions I know but this is
a UFO what why yes but if you're a part
of that brand that's what you signed I
think is the justification for keeping
the secret
tell you what though I can tell you what
the surgeon you don't think they have
contracts where they can't just go hey
you can't work on it and then go on a
nine news tomorrow in announces oh wait
why would they do that with a UFO I
don't understand it's because they know
we don't know how long beam so your that
argument so you're saying this secrecy
it's been there for 15 years here's the
reason why they don't want the world
known we have the technology whoever
graphs that technology and breaks it
down can run the world if you can
somehow manifests how powerful this is
but it may be to control everything but
what about all the religions out there
when they find out that there's a larger
being that's bigger than their dog this
is Fae God to make so the government
assets so the US government cuz we can't
release this the US government whoever
that is because you guys haven't told me
yet let's just say it's a group of
people it's not a cover more you don't
mess with in the government Ryan you
really don't think there's secret
societies within the gun I can't believe
you don't that's all Ange is that that
one say all what I'm saying is that no I
think that it's just one dude and he's
the president no no it's gone no no no
you hearing me other branches that
you're not hearing me you're not getting
her we are here
the CIA the Defense Department there I
think there are 19 different
intelligence agencies so you don't
believe hold on can I just say one thing
in your argument we go
you don't think there's nothing to the
word secret in secret you're Marilyn
you're talking about service you're
talking about something so different
right now what I've seen is if there's
seed there there are branches within the
government that know you're not telling
you [ __ ] you don't you don't tell me
anything I don't know but what you guys
what I'm saying to you guys is you're
all going down there telling me there is
an extraterrestrial technology okay yeah
that the US government's had for I guess
it's how many years old we don't know
we've been here about Roswell since the
50s let's quit up we've been here okay
so let's just stay v let's say it's 68
years please guys if you could tell me
how in the [ __ ] you think the US
government whether it's a secret or the
deep state or whoever you want to call
okay how the [ __ ] are you gonna keep
that a secret where would it get out B
because because the end of the day we
don't know we don't know we need Rendon
the Freedom of Information Act you can't
you have access to anything we try to
stage a coup in Iran that's called the
freedom of everybody's I'll have access
to everything we don't have actually you
don't have access to everybody access to
state secrets guys I understand that I
understand the Big Dance and now that
there are seat there are secrets that
the US and all governments have in their
intelligence service yeah Harper said
that we'll never get out and one of the
big problems is civilian oversight which
we're supposed to have and sometimes the
CIA takes license and we don't know
about it and then it gets blown up
you're on contra lots but what about the
JFK files like that where they can't
release it because we can't release some
it to the public because we don't want
the backlash from the pub what about
some messenger you see what's what's so
funny to me is guys always say this they
always go well they can't release it
because there'd be mass hysteria and
there'd be a huge backlash who's they
you mean they've signed who's they so
somehow you guys think that if you're in
the CIA or you're in defense
intelligence or your or your whatever
you are here soon they're liable to join
you guys are assuming that that that
that like they're open all day
curious nobody there is curious and so
and nobody's there's curious and that
it's really easy to keep secrets for 50
60 80 you're you're wrong about that I
think you're wrong if you think no
secrets are being held for the last 100
years yeah fair enough you think they're
not of course they are it's all out
there yes is keeping secrets for 70
years huh
you don't think they have any secrets
you think all of it's out in public
historians would laugh in your face
don't leave a high and it becomes a
matter of record we know everything that
went on in World War II kit we know
everything that went on world war two
wheelers then went on via I know pretty
much everything went off and be a bit
know some secrets we do everything we
know about the Phoenix our website
government lets you we know about the
assassination programs they didn't put
out ever you think they put out
everything like after a while in any in
any government when people die and were
they retire and stuff this information
comes out no the person passed and not
all the jobs they worked on the secrets
that they've had all these so yours a
government release so it is your
position I want to hear this I want to
hear you say this out loud it is your
position gentlemen that the governor has
secrets that the government has kept and
I'm gonna give you a number because it
this goes back to the 50s oh well there
is a that there is a UFO out there or
just some extraterrestrial technology
somehow landed in American hands because
it landed in Nevada let's just say I'll
give that to you now
no they're not now are you saying
whatever there are you gentlemen saying
to me that somehow the CIA the secret
see yeah so the CIA core has a secret
for the second oh the CIA that that
[ __ ] that that organization that's
not a bureaucracy at all really knows
how to keep secrets
know what I'm saying that's insane are
you saying that we have kept this UFO
technology and this you had the
existence here a secret from the
American people and the world for 68
years yeah yeah and it's yeah and it's
in a and it's in a UH tray a huge
building somewhere in area 51 really
don't dance because over six years we've
been trying to get Brian try golden or a
51 right why why did it take this is
awesome president will you listen can
you shut the [ __ ] up it's every
president before Clinton always said
there's no such thing as area 51 and
then it's not government over every
president Bill Clinton was the first one
to ever go yeah there is and I do
recognize there see with science there
are secret sites we have a secret it's a
secret but why don't I just want you
guys keep a nice idea and say they're
not know but I didn't say that document
this is open to the public
I'm not saying the government doesn't
have secrets we have intelligence you
said it all get up saying is that you're
not keeping a secret who's not a deer's
the kind you are there are secrets
everything's here 100 years how that
really even in Vietnam that's ok even
Vietnam we know it you crazy you have
access to anything right here you are
[ __ ] insane I love how you guys love
it
so who's keeping it is it why you think
the government's just wide over me oh so
you think everybody that's in the Secret
Service just good open but but hey
that's what I did they make this right
they making this jump caustic to UFOs so
no no no here you can spread across the
board release just all info letter said
that who said you didn't use you guys
don't know you're I'm his brother you
don't like this Brennan you don't listen
we're live we're not a listener quiet
everyone quiet both of you I know more
about history than both Oh
I'm more educated than you are I'm more
educated about the government politics
because I scarlet it is both of you
you're nodding your infant's right now
be quiet
Wow be quiet not so hot because you're
ignorant listen to me how is your on
Alou what I'm saying no secret why is he
is that it's very far-fetched to imagine
guys that the government is able just
able to keep a secret for 68 years about
a UFO that exists that's very
far-fetched to believe that's all I'm
saying guys and why am I saying that
because at the end of the day with with
the US government the way our government
works and let me give you my logic for a
second please the way the US government
works is eventually with the Freedom of
Information Act eventually when the
secrets are considered when when
national security secrets are no longer
considered important to keep it is made
available historians and lots of people
are interested in this stuff okay now
hold on hold on before I say that you
would if you did have technology that
was a UFO guys that was 68 years old and
let's say it's too extraterrestrial
are you following me it's a it's really
important technology there would be have
to be some kind of governing body that
legislated that would that made it a law
right there would have to be and I still
haven't found that so when you guys can
Israel you know when you got but don't
jump today know all all about government
did you study in college no no I'm not
angry you're just so if you're going
you're going Brian you know all about
government I'm saying no that's what you
just told us no no I didn't I said you
said we're infants you are let me
explain a little bit about how
government works
you do need policy that would make when
this know I've been lawful looking very
smart people most very smart people kind
of go okay why do you think all this go
you have photos Rogen's not smart
are you smarten Rogen I don't know what
are you talking about why are you
bringing Rogen into this you just said a
lot of the podcast oh yeah I got his
podcast it's very fun and intriguing to
believe that a UFO exists it is it's
[ __ ] fun I give it to you it's so fun
why though guys is it always hearsay
why do I have a guy who worked there and
he's telling us that he
got it and all we're left with correct
me if I'm wrong is cannot to have to
believe him can I get some evidence
police so you don't believe anything
less you have evidence
nothing is realities of evidence Brennan
is that fair am I being a dick about
that I just need some evidence what
about the videos they have you're gonna
say they're fake show them to me but you
can bring them up like and again every
video I do every three option but
everybody wants it great clear enough
though yes [ __ ] Evan yeah do you believe
chaos do you believe that I don't know I
can't say they're not okay there you go
come on guys like I need more than that
and you do too no no I'm not you're
you're being very um how do I say it
what but did you see what I'm saying
dude I just need some evidence Joe I
need evidence
check oh yeah there there's a lot of
evidence out there especially with area
51 is there though right yeah there's a
lot of there's a lot admit that it look
I'm saying is that am i bad am i wrong
for being cynical am i wrong for being
am i ignorant for being cynical when I
when it when and what I mean by how the
government works guys and I'm sorry that
I sound like a dick when I say that I
know more I'm just talking about the way
the government works there are there
always legislature you have to pass and
be you they're here I'm sorry you might
know more about the government Congrats
that's great Aaron oh that's great you
spent time studying it they're fantastic
anyone can learn it
yeah what I'm saying to you is it's not
crazy to think that the government keeps
secrets course not say that of course
the government has secrets whether it's
aliens whether it's war whether it's
maybe seal Mitch's sure it's not crazy
or some far-fetched world that they hide
evidence from the pub locator not public
don't think you have a snob we don't
think a UFO though would be like say so
everywhere all of us
pilots everybody go like this what the
[ __ ] is that right so think about you'd
have to be like we found our UFO
who are you gonna tell who found it who
are you gonna tell and why keep that a
secret
why wouldn't you though but I don't want
we said no one received area isn't a
very big factor in that ye be majesty I
don't think that would be mass hysteria
dude you don't think that I tell you the
whole world that there is a larger life
that religions aren't ready
yeah that everyone has believed in this
God which you probably believe in which
has no facts by the way I don't I don't
know isn't what you're just saying that
you want facts but yet all these
religions are based off of hearsay as
well as the mythology and Anna Anna Anna
but they're still facts there's no facts
there's no facts there's no
documentation about Jesus Christ that's
exactly right so I tend to be a little
bit of an agnostic like I'm like I don't
know but all I'm saying is there's no
when they say that they do have a higher
life form who's had his head though
right if the cover of releases that
information just imagine what happens
with every single religion that every
every every group that's out there that
just believes in a specific religion it
would be so hold that we have more legit
evidence that aliens than we do violate
on what he's saying because that's what
I meant when I say this is not how
government works let me just let me just
say this okay great so now what your
suit is assuming is that there is a
policy in the US government that would
that's there there's a group of people a
governing body yeah there would have to
be that has say-so on whether or not the
information is public the public should
know about something hunter based on
whether or not it creates mass hysteria
so so so so that that can you tell me
what that who is that body just tell me
who it is
do you know cuz I don't I I don't know I
know I want to say study the government
like I don't know if one agents hold on
but even that you're hey bee bees ain't
hold on but beep I know you studied
again history you keep telling us
because you don't know it's not real
well because you don't know that brain
nobody else does either can you tell me
who it would be conservative someone
they might have liability right for you
to sit here and act like that that the
government lied about area 51 that's a
branch of government that was
controlling that area know if you treat
that area
Thoma if you dry dairies 51 it says you
will be shot change kill yeah pacifiers
that's a government body right here you
know about it yeah same thing with this
but yet the President of the United
States was saying there was no such
thing as area 51
look can I just say there are secret
areas Joe doesn't mean that there you
have oh Aaron all right
you say what you were saying who are
these governments oh there's one right
there Brian they get it they get a
technology and in the room a bunch of
guys go in the room and once you guys go
and by the way they're military guys
would imagine right no white right well
watch they go we can't tell the American
public or the world is because there'll
be mass hysteria okay all the terrorists
did that happen long time with terrorist
attacks but we also know about well no
we don't you remember we used to have
the we used to have the threat levels
about remember that those are gone right
levels those are gone well because they
were just in effect that people weren't
but also I know guys who were to quote
you I know guys who are in that business
you go oh my god if we announced on CNN
yes exactly threat level a hundred
percent B mass hysteria we cannot do and
also we we don't want to tip off that
there are a lot of reasons for that
right there are a lot of reasons and I
agree 100% this head guys goes it would
be massive stories the US government
does want to scare the [ __ ] I read there
are real threats out there right a
hundred percent what I'm trying to say
is this if they found a UFO hmm and it's
there and let's we let's be honest we're
talking about it going back to the 50s I
don't personally see how in the world I
be how you go I need evidence here I
need evidence that you don't think they
can keep a secret I don't see why you
think for 68 years no you don't think so
you think so everything's out in the
groups some past significant 68 years I
mean every UFO yeah be everything how
about a marriage the most no secrets I
think so oh come on yeah you're just
playing devil's advocate no I'm not all
secret let's just stick to it no let's
let's go big in UF so you're voting a
hanger how are you gonna keep that a CEO
forty a 68 years honestly do you really
think we get people to see ya yes why
there's a shitload mass hysteria so they
go can't do it and everything you know
that you know it's all civilian
oversight so somebody in the civilian
government Trump would have to know
wouldn't he
every president we've ever had would
have to know and their chief of staff
well that's right that was this would
we're not wouldn't wouldn't win the
White House over all correct that's just
not a Secretary of State defense
secretary of defense yeah the
undersecretary fans all the people that
hat are responsible those people are
first of all sifted
civilians they're appointed they come in
kind of with their own agenda
we know that the White House can never
keep secrets right they're always
[ __ ] backstabbing each other secret
but they're always backstabbing each
other yeah so these people know and
every demonstration every administration
has known this right even though it's
top secret
I do really think that that somehow
every president says we can't release
this because it's top secret like I know
it's fun to believe
I just need can I get a little evidence
you think all presidents don't really do
you think they don't die with secrets
you think you're all everything's open
but I said of course they do sane just
UFOs oh yeah no I'm saying well secrets
are we have an intelligence community
right and yes and there's top-secret
clearance all right and so you you if
you say anything it's treason you go to
jail correct you can even be sentenced
death correct right so one I'm not
saying that the US government doesn't
have secrets based on a credible threat
China Russia whatever it is right 100%
we have an intelligence apparatus a very
big one with a blank check basically I
am still trying to figure out why in the
world UFOs would be kept secret from us
and I don't believe that answer Joe you
can't believe that we don't understand
why you don't want tell we need a move
on where you can keep going circles and
you guys show you guys percentage-wise
know where remember we're idiots
yeah percentage-wise percentage-wise way
too guilty percentage-wise you're
telling me what do you think do you
think that that I can't get up on a
hanger and hanger
what do you think I don't know but I do
I think I know for sure the government I
would bet my life on it
withheld secrets from us oh well not
know about about UFOs about every
thought every time well you know you
can't just say one thing to you if they
also I was talking about but there's
always he got me mad was that you guys
are jumping over here and going you're
saying no secrets no guys I'm not saying
that we're talking about specifically
this guy talking about how he worked on
a UFO I don't believe him listen he's a
liar okay
I'm sure what her friends they [ __ ]
nails in the knife well yeah it's not
too hard to believe because I know that
guy and I'll show you after we're done
that that's a little easier to believe
isn't it that a guy had a pocketknife
and Hondas nails my UFO what's crazy to
me and why you get so hostile Bella no
but yeah it's crazy you know everything
about the history and were small
everything about history people know
history and exactly what you guys are
applying you guys are saying [ __ ] you
say you say van a knife right now I
describe you do I describe you know this
and you're smart guy and I'm not saying
this to diminish you anything I would
say there's smarter people who defend
the alien stuff chef's know the
government better than yes yeah well no
no no I'm telling you there are it went
there Ike smart dude you're always
running late
yep you forgot your socks it's not
[ __ ] for your sock yeah did you
forget your sock yeah we're infants but
you forgot that's not fair dude you're
late to work you're being rather than
traffic because you live here it's work
you know what time this start yeah yeah
like you forgot yourself now you guys
are fighting me right now as I did yeah
suck I'd say that's about maybe one of
the greatest cause that I know about you
guys are impotence I went to college in
state history behind you and telling me
that I was saying I was insane you are
at best you're too cool attention all
dry
you were smart you are Brian you in do
can't talk to him smart little people
don't understand me what happened Sammy
keep up you smart man you're so so so so
smart man I am we should stop it we're
ten which we can't we should even be in
your present it's just I just I should
need more evidence about UFOs that's all
I do like I don't believe the government
casts secrets or would keep it a secret
yep you're right they can or no I win
and I don't believe that era of judges I
don't think you can keep it co for 60
years about a UFO in a hangar in area 51
or anywhere else I don't know it's
possible if you say bro well we're and
you guys you to change the diapers you
need to rethink your government doesn't
work we can't tell anybody it'll get rid
of religion go read a book Joe I'm gonna
read a book on history on history at the
government I knew I knew once I did that
he'll read the book I would lose you
guys because he majored in the history
of college do you know that oh my god
and you're [ __ ] him I'm a [ __ ]
infant I'm sorry I'm sorry you have to
do that in this area true colors flat
out man
no no you were being insulting and you
were your house all insulted you were
going you open any secrets you really I
was like that's not what I say that's
fine you already started with that big
and then you went to you I did yeah yeah
you give it one day you don't keep
swaying you don't listen what you do in
seven you go and you jump so it's more
likely to believe no no I'm gonna jump
in I'm gonna jump in you know why he
gets defensive
cuz when you talk anything you throw a
little pz2 meaning you're demeaning and
you do this sorry I have a brain you
don't have a brain understand why you
believe in like like aliens but I'm a
human being with a brain it's very
educated brain so I understand so I said
I should have had a better approach yeah
I was loving something I didn't know one
like to get talked like I was little
Joe got heated well he's a dick he was
super I can't wait you don't you don't
believe in right here's right ducktail
you're not I'm in the middle yeah what
I'm saying is then I know this for a
fact I don't know you don't know right
yeah neither one of us knows Joe doesn't
know no one knows sir so when you're so
diehard set on it I wasn't just weird I
just I just I don't have a dog if there
are aliens fantastic there's not all
right you know what it is when a guy on
gets on Rogan and he worked there and he
talks about it I kind of go you didn't
listen to it though I didn't listen
that's the first problem that you only
have evidence to back that but is there
any job to consider any government
agencies is there anybody you listen to
it and then report back okay fourth all
right there call Rosen and go dude would
you tell what do you think that was he
full of [ __ ] yeah it's like Textron yo
dude is that guy full of [ __ ] what'd he
say no yeah fit you want to say it you
guys you're so quick to do it to us yeah
right now no we're infant hey Logan Joe
Ryan wants to call you something full of
[ __ ] I gotta Jamie I apologize college
bro I didn't mean that
Joe didn't go to college
what to call you that leather shoes a
historian mr. Joe Rogan uh go ahead tell
them come on I'm sorry
say it he believes in the same story
that we believe in say it looks a to its
[ __ ] face man no I can't wait a night
spicy baby bro folks cry don't squat
against cries please I'm sorry I just
don't believe in UFOs okay until I steal
all small all of the small you know
everyone's an infant everyone set your
camera right there just men in wake up
naturally and that's when the historian
becomes a [ __ ] let's get out of here
man wait let's go undo it anymore
no we don't have to go now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]